hier soir quand j'étais lancés à ses
trousses
c'est là que ça commence
elle modifie ce que je vois les sky et
il s'étire 7éme illusion d'optique
illusion qui ensuite a disparu des
archives et c'est pas fini
juste après je vois un métro à l'arrêt
sur le quai de la station
un métro qui n'existe pas
à céret une image en mouvement en temps
réel
qui peut pirater renaître humain
on va faire pour la stopper on va faire
ce qu'on fait toutes les victimes on va
l'embaucher
depuis ce faire pour vous
la fille était pas répertorié aucune
empreinte numérique
elle gagne sa vie en camouflant des
liaisons secrètes c'est une maîtresse de
l'édition capable de remplacer ce qu'on
veut plus voir dans nos archives le plus
important c'est qu'elle s'efface elle
même
maintenant c'est nos clients qui seront
effacés
un tel niveau d'anonymisation pourrait
rendre tous les crimes possibles
l'anonymat c'est l'ennemi quelqu'un tue
mes clients en essayant faire croire que
c'est
elle te manipule
je ne suis pas en sécurité
et toi non plus
on doit pouvoir croire nos cieux
le système s'écroule
la voie est libre
vous pouvez y aller
on peut vivre dans l'anonymat
effacé ta vie
j'entretiens son souvenir qu est ce qui
m mal à ça
regardez en arrière